so my name is Giovanni Manzoni I'm a
shoe designer at good into driven and
the talk is a panda's from be date range
to white long these are basically the
first of abetik of thing that I could
find in the partners API and this is the
latest one so that's why the title is
talk so I be the mound myself now first
the slides are part of the longer public
course doing data science with python
that i teach here in Amsterdam if you
liked this tutorial you love the course
and if you don't like this tutorial you
also love course really no reason not to
go to the course if you're new to python
and data science and I beat them on
myself I'm italian-born 32 years ago
last Tuesday I move to the netherlands
10 years ago before it was cool to move
abroad from Italy so before a financial
crisis it means I somehow got a master
refused philosophical degree enlightened
in theoretical physics here in the
Netherland I also managed to get four
kids in the meantime so the means about
PhD students having a lot of free time
is totally true because I could manage
to do both at the same time and that's
also the reason I have disproportionate
amount of caffeine in my blood so I
might talk too fast just tell me that
after graduating I went for two one for
one year at kpmg where I was PowerPoint
monkey I was doing I was doing software
code reviews basically for big
corporations banks and and government
after that good attitude Weaver made me
an offer I couldn't refuse and last year
i made my next career step and became
shoe designer I got into driven and that
means that if you you get custom design
night shoes if you come work for us
we're hiring and offer that I couldn't
refuse didn't evolve horses or horses
hats or blood or the sort of stuff if
you want to write
about a tutorial so panel is probably
the most widely known library in the PI
data ecosystem and it was probably on
par with new PI and sci-fi it was
initially developed by West McKinney
while he was working as a quant and he
kind of got fed with what you could do
with the existing tools mostly Excel I
think and say basically started this is
well he's owned his own library with
with Python and I heard was talking
about it and he said from the beginning
one of the focus of bundles was about
speed I work in finance and speed it's
extremely important and you can really
see all the cares that he put into the
performance tests that are in pandas and
everything so once you're using things
in punish you can usually expect them to
be much faster than what you would write
yourself so we'll see how grew by works
in in pandas we saw that Peter and the
keynote also had a slide on how to do
grew by in pure python I have nothing
against peter burkett but i can assure
you the partner solution it's much much
faster because of the way new pie words
of the way was architected at the
library and all the other contributors
hot to him now it's not anymore the core
contributor but it's a really left foot
print on the on a project the API is
really large so instead of showing
everything I'll try to show the most
important stuff if you're ready no
pandas some part of the tutorial might
be boring we do have exercises though
which you might or might not complete if
you don't do them then you'll have just
to wait a couple of minutes while the
others are doing that and please do ask
questions otherwise you'll have an early
lunch if we finish too early so the
basic responders well what I usually use
so step back who's familiar with the
Jupiter and / ipython notebook
yeah okay a lot of you guys very good so
all this talk and and the slides are
made with the Jupiter notebook you can
use that in the while we do the tutorial
you don't have to but I really strongly
encourage you to do so in the notebook
we you basically begin like this I at
least me I begin like this I important
in pi then I import some mud claw clip
to make plots as we will see in the next
part of the talk and then I'm poor
pandas the PI data convention of
importing pandas is to imported SPD so
please don't import everything from
panda so from partners import start
that's bad and give it a short name
because to be using it a lot we start
off with series who knows what new PI
arrays are okay so this is a good chunk
of using a dozen so basically new empire
raise our see like data structure that
you can manipulate impugn in a Python
through new pipe and why is this
important because in the it turns out
that once you have this I mean a lot of
work has been done to vectorize
operations on these arrays and by
vectorizing operation means sending
chunks of this array into the 302 a
one-page of the your processor and doing
things in parallel in your processor so
that means that operations on this new
buyer race which you can think about
them as Python this more or less
extremely inaccurate which is for the
sake of the tutorial and and do math
operations on them so pandas extends the
concept of new empire race with series a
theory is just a new empire ray like
this with an index and you can either
pass the
index or pandas will automatically
assign an index to your series so we can
see here that we just create a series
with this list there's a Python list
bund us under the hood attached and
index to it and transform the Python
list into a new pie array and it also
tries to guess the best type which in
this case is in 264 can you actually see
from the back of the room LD yes okay
great we can access the values of the
series so we could see judge is just an
array of in 64 but we could also access
the index of the array so we see here
that it's basically it's under the hood
is another new PI array and it also has
the n64 type so we can't specify the
index ourselves if we want so in this
case I'm creating another theory with
index ABCD and we can see now that the
series as the index light specified and
the same component here so now you are
wondering why should I put an index on
my data structure on my series and the
answer is that we can access by index so
if we do things like series 2 and then
be I will get a new serie with only the
B element if I want to access the value
at being I need to use just a single
bracket so you see the difference here
in the first example I'm getting back a
new theory and a second I'm just getting
back the element just war and you could
also select multiple sorry multiple
elements in the series so here I want a
new theory which is just the B and C
elements of the previous one so that's
all possible and you can work with
series basically in the same way you can
work with new
iras so you could call new pipe mean of
the Siri and it will reply you can
series also have built-in methods like
you could call me to a series and it
will give the same answer under the hood
it basically does the same thing so
performance wise it's exactly equivalent
of what you do or mostly equivalent you
can also do nice things like I want to
square the element of the Siri and you
can just invoke that well star star too
and you will get a square series back
and it's all done in this vectorized
free optimized fashion so that doing
this it's between it probably 50 and 150
times faster than the pure python way
especially with very large series you
can select using a series of boolean so
if I call Siri Siri to larger than zero
I will get a new Siri which is composed
of boolean and each element represent
whether Siri to is larger than zero so
we get a through true folds fold this
effectively is just a new series which
contains boolean as the d-type informs
us here having that you can use this
theory to get a slice of the original
theory so here I'm getting back a series
where all the elements are larger than
zero and this is the answer you could
also do well use the in operator that
will check if a is in 32 here know that
the answer is true because a is in the
index of cerrito we can also load data
from dictionaries so here there's a
literacy percentage dictionary which is
just some made-up data
and these are the Dutch provinces so not
all enjoyed holon flavor on groningen
you can see the flavor I'm the one where
I live as the lowest literacy percentage
of them all I heavily contribute to that
and then we can turn that into a series
and you can see that the keys of the
dictionary will become the index of the
series and while the values will become
the art well the values of the searing
again the d-type is assigned
automatically and panels try to do the
smart thing there yeah yeah I think I
have it in a later slide but they should
be hashable well of course if there are
keys of a dictionary they should be
hashable anyway but if you're passing an
index not to the dictionary then they
should be hashable so you cannot pass a
list as an element of an index of punish
know so the question is does it flag an
error if you pass something which is not
hashable or is it transforming the
answer is I mean the last time I checked
it gives you an exception saying that
the item is not actual not a good
question er if I want and I'm passing a
dick I can override the index that the
dictionary has so here I am passing a
different index which is this and as you
can see the chronium province falls out
of the series while the province is
serted with this sentinel value which is
not a number and panas does that because
the uterus province was not present in
the original data once you have this not
a number in your theory you can check
where they are with the is now method
and it will tell you that you dressed as
a another number as its value we can
also give the series a name and index of
the syrian name so here we say the name
of series should be literacy and the
name of the index should be province and
this is what we get back these are
unfortunately in place operations so
they change the underlight series which
I are not always like because I'm a
functional kind of guy and the index can
also be changed on place so now here we
make copy of the literacy series 2 and
then we say the index should be this for
element and then you can see that the
index of literacy series 3 change your
place this is potentially very dangerous
because you you are actually changing
out this you can access this and here we
have the remark that ready go mate index
values must be hashable data frame
what's the data frame so data frame you
can think of it as an excel file where
you have an index on the rose but also
the name of the columns there so it's
basically a by dimensional series or
with a collection of two or more
illnesses one for the rows and one for
the columns and we'll see later that we
can also move the illnesses so to index
or three index for the rows and two or
more indices for the columns each column
here in that data frame as a different
value
kabhi a numeric could be a strain could
be a boolean so on and they can be
created in a lot of different ways we
will see how to create them
programmatically and we'll see towards
the end of the tutorial are we can
create them by reading a file so here i
have another dictionary the data
dictionary where the value of each key
is a list and if I just pass it to the
data frame structure I get back this
here i'm naming my data frame DF it's
kind of the convention but please don't
use it to production because everybody
names things like DF then you'll be
overriding your variables but it's fine
for the talk i think we can change if
you want the order of the columns so we
can see here that we have literacy
province here and now we have promised
your literacy because we passed the
column order here we can pass an index
as well if we want to overwrite this
year and we can also pass new column
names that will result in missing data
so if I would add a new column name here
that doesn't exist in data I will get a
whole new column with another numbers
creating new columns and assigning
values is very easy so we can see here
that I'm creating a new nonsense column
which is just a year column / the
literacy color here I'm also presenting
out the way that you have to access the
data which is in a column so you have
two options one of them using the dot
notation that obviously only work if
your column name do not have spaces in
it and if your column name is not a
built-in method of the of the data frame
for example if you name a column some
you cannot call the add some to get a
value what you need to do
say DF bracket quote some closing quote
closing bracket so this is also the way
we used to get column value so we have
here our our new DF with a nonsense
column which as the name says it's
nonsense and what we can do we can also
create a new columns by passing a series
here's something really important
happens in that my serie as the index 1
3 & 4 1 3 & 4 and the values are 0 1 & 2
so pandas automatically aligns my serie
with the data frame index and where data
is missing you get an um questions up to
here yeah
do you know if that's implemented in
such a way that it's a sensible to have
a large series that's mostly Nan's
memory wise do dunno under the hood so
like if I'm making a sparse matrix is it
disastrous for my memory footprint if I
represent it this way I mean if you
don't know that's fine I don't have the
answer I know that if I mean if you're
making sparse matrix of course the side
by sparse package its way to go I don't
know internally I mean none is just a
sentinel value for bugless and punish
there's a lot of machinery to deal with
nuns that new pie doesn't have by
default so for example if you have you
want the mean of a series that has some
nuns in it funness automatically deal
with it well nooope I cannot I don't
know the specific there of the
performance penalty if you if you just
have mostly nuns in your data frame
however if I'm thinking about the use
case it usually does not happen so much
that you want to do operations on the
data frame which is full of nuns you
usually first filter them out in some
way and then do your operations because
otherwise you're just shooting yourself
in the foot not using sci fi sparse
package
how oh yeah sure can you can you tell me
what the advantages of using a series
instead of a data frame with one column
that's good question so you have some
methods are only available to series and
thump thump only to data frames I don't
have now the all the methods that that
only work on one or the other I know one
of them at least in there in the one of
the latest version was value count so if
you want to do a value counts you need
to have a seat a theory and it doesn't
work on data frame and and so on so the
API is not perfectly symmetrical between
the two so depending on which method you
want to call you might be better off
with a series or with a data frame the
nice thing is that it's very efficient
to go from one to the other if you just
use the dot notation on a data frame
column you'll get a series back and you
can very easily pass a series to it to
the data frame constructor to get the
data frame so it's that really depends
on your use case but I will know about
performance wise if that I don't think
in marriage it really matters what
you're choosing
we can also pass to the data frame
structure a dictionary whose values are
dictionaries in this case you see that
this 0 1 2 3 4 will become the index and
these values will become the values of
the literacy column so we see here so
this policy is very smart and figuring
out what it should do as you can see i
could have pure none here like syriza
lied to and i will get a nun here the
same if i would have omitted this guy
here if this was not here the result
would have not change partners
automatically puts a nun there we
indexing we can also reindex so let's
say we have this series here which is
just the number from 0 to 9 with an
index from zip for all the even numbers
from 0 to 18 and let's say this series
actually represent the month of November
shall be in the month of not having the
month of November 31 days we need to
reindex so basically to insert all the
missing date and we can do that by using
the index method so we can see here that
I call the index of Siri tree and I say
I want every value between 0 & 3
actually November eyes 33 days so this
is wrong let's say it's December and
panels will automatically put nuns where
you don't have values of data in your
previous series this could be
problematic for you because for example
you say well actually if I didn't have a
data point my instrument or my my short
is assuming that the data for the first
of the summer is equal to the data to
the sorry its list for the second of
December is equal to the data or the
first of the summer so rare index as the
methods argument and you could say I
want to forward fill the series so what
happens is that if here I should have a
nun pandas will take the value of the
previous day and you can see how it
works here so all the evil all the odd
index values get the values of the
previous one up to 18 and from 18
onwards that was the last point in my
original series everybody gets a nine
value you also have sorry you also have
the back feel if you want the contrary
so the opposite yeah the index does it
have to be ordered in your early
examples just showed hashable things so
yeah to use the index with this method I
mean it well I mean if you're really in
the same it will take just a previous
one and if it's all I mean if it's all
red you may get what you want if it's
not order it you might need to order it
and we'll see how you order an index
later to get the result that you want
but you're correct okay in principle to
get precisely this result you get you
need to add things in the correct order
okay you have a question from the
audience ok I'll reindex also works on
columns so you could basically add a new
column like this and you have a row wise
interpolation so basically it tries to
do this mark things when you're adding
new columns another very interesting
thing is how to drop data which i do it
very often especially when it does not
agree with my mod
I work for a bank and just kidding so
here for example because what to drop
since column and if this is a column I
need to explicitly pass exes is one to
indicate that this should be a column
and you can see that the resulting data
frame does not have the nonsense column
anymore but I could also drop a row by
specifying the index of the row in this
case for and it will drop the side
poland row the latest one here in this
case i don't have to pass axis is zero
because that's default it's good to
mention you could also drop in place by
editor in place is true argument that
will modify the data frame in place and
will not return anything as we already
so we have a couple of ways to index and
filter a data frame the first one we can
as i said we can refer to a to a column
using the bracket notation and if you do
single bracket will get a Serie back if
you use the double bracket we can select
multiple columns and the results would
be a data frame you can see
statistically pandas makes difference
between series and data frame by adding
this Excel like cells to data frames and
not adding anything too serious so you
visually you always know what you're
getting back and market is very happy
and gave their visual talk yesterday he
really agree that these are the breeding
poor excuse to do your work we can as
with data frames we can select the data
using it sorry as with series you can
select data using boolean conditions so
for example I want the whole every rose
in the data frame where the nonsense
column is larger
5000 we get this here and we can also
use fancy indexing with the dot X opera
method in this case i'm saying i want
the first and the fourth rose but only
for the nonsense illiteracy column and
we get this data frame back and
functions as we as with the series
functions I mean data frames has
functions that you could use you could
use new pipe functions on numeric values
so for example I won't take a square
root of the literacy and nonsense column
and we'll get this again these are
vectorized operation so it's very
efficient to do much faster than the
pure Python version and sometimes you
want custom function for our data frame
so just to remember everybody this is
the data frame and we want a custom max
function what this function does is that
it collects all the elements of a column
if the column I mean if the element is
numeric so it's number float in the
church whatever and if there is anything
you want to get the maximum of the
sequence so the maximum of the column
otherwise just returned and none I can
use this function custom mugs I'm
wrapping here in to f4 to be short on
the f so for example i want to say apply
F on the f along the rows so you can see
here that I couldn't just apply the max
function on the Rose because i had
string values here so what i do instead
is I've wrote my castle max function
which ignores the string and you get
this back these applied row wise you can
also applied element and column wise
without specifying
axis and the results of the test 10
minutes for the break rate of I want
coffee sorry sorting is also possible so
coming back to the question that we had
from front row we can sort by index with
a short index or we could sort by sorry
by row and we could sort by column again
since shorting it's done in a computer
science sort of way capital letters are
not the same as non capital letters so
nonsense gets at the end because it's a
non-capital slower case now we could
sort by values this actually recently
change in i think- odot 17 this metal is
new and the old sort method is
deprecated so here what I do I'm sorry
by literacy the values of the literacy
column and then I'm sorting by index so
you could see here that Oh point 5s as
first second index element and then the
fourth index element because I sorted by
this column first by this column second
the short values and sword index they
both have that I think it's called the
reverse method together in sorting
revert now that you could use panas also
has a descriptive statistics a lot of
descriptive statistics functions built
in so for example well as we already so
we could get a son of a particular
column we could get the sum of every
column into the data frame and please
load what happens with province so
pandas doesn't choke on that it's just
well does the right thing in Python
because when you some string in Python
you just concatenate them and you can
also some using I mean on the rose by
passing
x is equal to 1 and as you can see
numeric non numeric values are ignored
so province here has been ignored then
we have the disk described method for a
data frame and described basically takes
all the columns numeric columns and it
prints some descriptive statistics as
you can see on the slide and if I also
on statistics on non-numeric column I
can use that include all keywords and i
will get also some facts about the
province column which is non-numeric
like many unique promises we have the
top frequent and how much time it
appears but we don't get anything for
all the other statistics of course
quenches up to here no okay yeah these
also data fit
dress and thanks so I may correct that
apply under hood and the hood tries to
vectorize the computation for this
particular column and also like
additional question there are some some
cases when we need for example to apply
some up to apply some function to each
row do something again apply some
function to each row in the data frame
so basically it can be knife through
apply function but there are some cases
then we need for example to do some like
database query for example for each row
in the data frame and my question is
does pandas have some implementation
drew the hood which allows to do such
things in parallel I mean like for each
row if you do some operation
independently for each row thats pandas
have disability so off the top of my
head I don't know the exact answer it's
a bandage they are working really hard
to release in the gill the global
interpreter lock to be able to do that
so that's why one way to do that the
other thing so in principle should be I
mean it should be able to do this things
in parallel in the future the other
thing that maybe it's also worth
mentioning it's about opening all the
connections to the database every time
you try to call the function or a row
which could potentially be very
expensive and for that you have two
options one is to use a class to do that
which I don't like and the other user
coroutine so basically have the you know
what routines are ya so you basically
use a coroutine and you pause the
execution and you try to to have to keep
the connection open by using that so
basically pausing the execution every
time you finish with a row but leaving
the connection always open so basically
do it in a single transaction your whole
thing does that answer
yeah well I didn't really answer it but
do you want you to ask more oh it's your
time yeah um yeah what I was talking
about before is value count value count
is a really invaluable methods he
basically count how many instance of a
value you have in a column this is a
series method so you can for example
apply to the DF province series the
output is another series where the index
are the values that you find in the
column and the values are how many times
you see that in that particular column
so you can see that yes the index values
is this flavor lon Ordonez out Hollen
which is the same output that you would
get if you call the unique element on
the DF province series you can see that
it's perfect exactly the same we also
have met vectorized membership so if you
want to select all the provinces which
are either flevoland or result Holland
you can use that is in method which is
extremely fast so much faster than that
than the pure python the operation here
so here what we get is the data frame
with filter allowed promises and now we
go to handle a missing data or a
questions up to here now good that means
everybody sleeping so Henley missing
data so if every letter said you have a
gut did not have missing data you're
probably in the wrong room so I see want
gentlemen it is going out and assuming
that all the others did have a missing
data in there and there are data let's
go on so what a value is not present we
already show that you get the nun
Sentinel which is just and pin em under
the hood and that value is used as a
place holder which is easy to detect so
for example if you want to detect where
Syria line is as now values we just
called is now and we can see that it
returns true if we have a nun and if
return false in all the other cases very
powerful so we just said that we have
this this nun Sentinel in upon us and
using that none Sentinel you could do
nice things so for example you can use a
drop and a method to drop all the rows
that contains not a number in the series
so if i just take series of line that
had two lot of numbers and i call drop
an a I will get this back if I use the
same method on a data frame it's kind of
brutal because it takes out every row
that has at least one na into the data
frame which is a well as I said it's
kind of brutal and you could also use
different methods like Phil na in this
case I want to replace every not a
number with a zero you can use whatever
value you want for example here use the
neighbor number E and you also have the
flexibility to pass oh sorry it goes
into maybe it's an exercise well anyway
you have the flexibility to pass a
dictionary here where the keys are the
name of the columns and the values is
the value they should replace for na s
in that column so you could potentially
say i want to feel the na in the promise
column with I don't know limber and the
value for the series align
na with the MPE and you could do that so
passing a dictionary to fill in a work
is very useful a few slides back your
head is null instead of is none is there
any particular reason that no I think
you filtered so here we have now here
that's why why is not where you're
filtering for none well because so I'll
probably a philosophical region
basically when pundits does not find the
value so a value which is non-existent
it puts out and pee none which is just a
sentinel and then they decided to name
the method to kind of I don't know to
convey that it was non-existent okay
because there is none by is none yeah
there is none which is another n 0 and e
I mean that I know is na n oh yeah oh
I'm just confused we will see the
difference it's because you could have
think I mean am now your call me of God
but it's a there's a difference because
you in how you also treat infinite
values so you have NP none and NP ends
which are two different things and if I
recall correctly is now and is none they
treat the infinite value differently I
think we'll have an example about it in
a few slides okay thank you yeah as I
said as I said before I don't know why
the two spies are switched anyway as I
said before dropping a can be really
brutal sometimes so you have the how
method that basically specify when
should you drop a row and one of the
possibilities is to use all I only want
to drop our row if every element is not
a number in this case nothing gets
dropped here or you have the threshold
key word that says I want to drop a row
if I if at least five elements in this
case are not none so in this case here I
have four elements which are not none so
two gets dropped 0 also has four
elements which are not none so also 0
gets dropped from this is this clear it
committed this treasure keyword actually
works the opposite of all my brain works
time I always have to look up the
documentation and that's why one of the
exercises is so well it's right and
other functions that you can easily drop
lines with more than n missing values so
the other way around so these are very
biased exercise because Taylor to my
brain but it's something that you could
definitely do in there in pandas however
because of time do a quick show hands I
think it's good if you do the exercises
not in the tutorial because we are
otherwise we won't have enough time is
that alright with you yeah okay great
another feature that pandas has is your
article indexing I'm going to go a bit
faster here basically you can have a
two-level index here as you can see a b
c and d and one two three are both part
of the index so the index has two levels
so here you can just keep the oldest
index how this is done you can you can
look it up in the notebook I just want
you to understand the concept here so we
have a two levels here of the index and
you could see that the index indeed is a
multi-level index with multiple labels
you could select everything concerning
to the be indexed what you get back is
this series here
and you can see that if I if I do that
the index of data be is just a simple
index so 100 the hood my a part of the
indexes is lost and I just get a simple
index here so this is effectively like a
normal a normal theory we can also
select data using the inner labels so
for example I want to select all the two
of the inner index I can use the syntax
here the column is necessary again this
is a normal series with a flat index we
can also have your article hynix in four
columns and in fact you will explore
that in the exercises that you'll do
whatever you want and now let's go to
the date of wrangling section that is
one of the most frustrating things to
get the data in the shape that we want I
usually spend probably more than half of
my time doing that and the other half of
I spending in meetings so I never do
anything so do yourself a favor and pay
attention to this chapter so the first
are the merge operation so let's let's
say we have this data frame which we
already presented which is pretty simple
and we wanted to merge it with the data
frame that contains the population of
these provinces it's very simple we
could call merge without any arguments
emerges smart and it compares the
columns from one data frame to the
columns of the other data frames and it
uses that to the merge so just calling
this you can see the panda fondness is
doing the right thing so adding the
population to the toward the original
data frame if you don't have the same
slice book that sounds like a mess if
you don't have the same column names you
need to explicitly say our
want to merge with the right data frame
on the province index lower p and on the
left data frame which is DF on the
capital province index you can see that
he openness does emerge just fine but
the province column is that it's double
so its present the beginning and at the
end here you could note one thing is
that the azide holland row is out
because by default merge does inner
joint so who knows the difference
between inner outer joins left okay well
not everybody so inner joint only the
common keys are preserved left joins
only the keys from DF are preserved the
right joint only the key from the f3 are
preserved and the full other joints all
the keys are preserved regardless of who
has them here is how we can change the
nature of the joint so for example here
we could do an outer join so we'd have
salt Hollen with other population and
PDF without all the other values because
I'd hold on what or was only in the f
and III was only there for and now I
want to get your attention here here
we're doing an outer emerge with a data
frame the f5 that that's twice the
flavor lunt entry so what pandas does it
creates for entries for flavor lon in
the final data set so the f only had two
flavel and programming entries however
the f5 has also to Flavell entries and
so ponders kind of do a cross join there
so you get four entries for flavor
learned in your final data set there's
something
that you I mean you need to know this
because sometimes it happens that you
get duplicate data for no particular
reason and you get this sort of behavior
so this is a many-to-many merge and as
you can see pan de azúcar plane it just
adds up yes mark yeah question is how to
remove duplicates I'm going to check it
in the next few slides so I'll postpone
your question don't feel abandoned again
exercises to to reinforce the knowledge
you just learn another nice thing we
could do is to that we might want to do
is to combine data with overlap so let's
take series a which is this and serie b
which is this and we may want to say i
actually want to combine it to series
taking the values from Serie A if I have
something in Serie A otherwise filling
the value from Serie B if I don't have
anything so for example the combined
theory would have zero in place of F and
2.5 for e because of how I want to do
things so there's that known pythonic
way to do this which is probably wrong
but don't blame me where I say well in
Serie A is now then takes ueb otherwise
if it's not now take serie a and then
attach the Serie A index to the data
frame to the series sorry which is very
involved and ugly and error-prone so
please don't use it the good way to do
that is to use combined first method so
basically pandas does the does exactly
this behind the scenes for you and the
result explicitly same so combine first
is a very powerful method that you could
use in series well again exercise
stacking and add stacking so who knows
what the tidy data is okay not many
so let's see we have this data here
which is the the result of a trade
treatment a and treatment B to this
patient so does anybody see a problem
with the data structure like this so
what if I want to have the whether i
should add two extra columns right one
for treatment a and one from treatment
be so it's very inefficient to do that
so the palace developers know that and
so they had a wide too long method that
basically what it does it takes my
patients data frame and then it looks
for the trt suffix in the column names
here two-tier to use the suffix to both
column names and then it says i'm going
to basically take everything that comes
a steer tea and put it in an index here
so that my data from a wide format
became a data in a long format now
adding things like whether it's much
more easier because it can just pass a
list and against it's very nicely
formatted data so if you can always try
to work with with the long form of data
because much easier to think reason
about itself if you want to get back to
where we were which you shouldn't but
you can you can use the pivot method
people to work a bit like what we think
it takes the index which is this and
then the treatment which is this and it
basically combines that with index so
what we get back is exactly where we
were so it's a bit complicated to see
that at the white boar in a boat I
imagine that is
to aiding but it's not very difficult
after use it twice it's good as you know
it's there and it takes a bit of
practice I think she is properly
remember removing duplicates that was a
mark question so this is the select
distinct in CQ if you know CQ let's say
we have this data frame here here we
don't have duplicate but what happens if
we so will basically get the same thing
back if we call the drop duplicate
method but what happens if we just want
to select the literacy and the province
immediately there we get duplicate
entries so which is this and this so
calling drop duplicates will give us
this new data frame here where all the
duplicates are removed applying a
function to a data frame is also
extremely yeah oh sorry what if you want
to drop duplicates for those two columns
but retain say for example the first
entry of the third column yeah you
joined you you would have to do a group
by operations and we'll see them in the
end of the talk so basically if you do
it doing a group by let's say you're
doing a group bible literacy and
province and then in the group I you can
decide what should happen with year
right is that yeah so we'll see group
buys at the end and how to do this kind
of windowing function to like select the
lowest here for little for prominence
literacy and that sort of stuff does
that answer the question yeah so
applying function is done with the apply
method here one justice know how long is
each color unsurprisingly five for all
of them I could also say how long is
each row again unsurprisingly tree for
all of them but I could do more
complicated things
so for example I could say if I if you
get a float element at to otherwise do
nothing so here I say the f6 apply a
float at two and the literacy gets
boosted immediately and years also gets
shifted of course it's a stupid example
but you can see how this may be useful
in your day-to-day practice again
exercises for you and I'll here's the
note the apply function tries to work on
aggregate basis so it tries to do the
operations in one pass so it tries to do
the operation in the new pipe way so
basically when you're adding 22 this
year column and you're basically passing
the whole column to the CPU at the same
time and it's the CPU is taking care of
adding two very efficiently however
sometimes you don't it can't always do
that and apply my fail in that case so
you can use it apply map function that
applies a function L cell by cell to put
it into in the Excel nomenclature so
sell buy sell or element by element the
function will be applied if you use
apply map so I've been trying this quite
a lot with to do like a case when type
of structure that I would have done is
equal yeah and I tried to write it first
as a as a function that I passed the
apply I think but the problem was that
came out really slow and then I started
using MP where instead which was like an
enormous improvement yeah you could see
an example there but what you can do of
course it's to pre-select your your data
with like the f brackets the f-series
larger than something and then apply
this function and then you basically
catenate that with the function that you
applied on the other region of the of
the of the data frame but using where
it's also very good way and probably
under the hood is happening the same
thing but of course Bonds takes care of
teaching thing back together for you so
I mean it both good way she'll go about
it thanks so and I also heard that or
continuing this the same topic mostly I
thought that there is some kind of
decorator like numb by UDF or something
you can apply to a function and numpy
tries to convert it to a vectorized
version which will be yes I the faster
and P dot vector eyes you mean yeah yeah
yeah so yeah so if you have a function
like well I wouldn't think of anything
now well a function that is not
vectorized by default and so it works an
element by element you can call and P
dot vector eyes on that and new pie's
try to sorry make a vector risible
version of that function which will be
faster than a non vector risible version
but it will be slower than that then the
optima then they built in vectorized
operation the new pipe has so for
example if you want to bake your own
version of some in a non vectorizing
away and then you vectorize it with with
the new by vectorized function it will
be faster than your original version but
slower than the pure numbaa version mark
function was being applied to each
column now in most practical
circumstances what I want to do is that
I want to combine multiple columns
together and be referencing them by name
and have this applied sort of role row
wise into an
or into an existing Road what is sort of
the best idiom to use yeah so if I'm if
I'm not mistaken and here you could you
could let me think I think you can
reference by square bracket like say if
you have like or bite and I think by
position so if you're passing if you're
passing a function that needs to take
the element of the first element of the
first column the third column you could
say it x0 and then we take that element
and x3 and it would take the four column
and you could combine them inside the
apply so here you could say l0 and it
will take literacy and then l2 and it
would take here and you could do stuff
together and I'm pretty sure you can do
it by phi x position and i'm not sure if
you could also do by name so I'm just
saying EK's literacy that I have to
check it out
also replacing values so sometimes we
wish to replace values from a data frame
so for example in this case we clearly
have some outliers here the 999 values
and we want to basically replace them
with something else one of the way we
could do is to just use the replace
value here so we say every time you see
a 999 I want to replace it with the
median of the column so for column 0 9
99 will become the median of the column
for column 1 and so on so it's very
powerful yeah this one actually has a
first exercise an error well another an
inconsistency because here i'm using the
medium but i was doing the example here
where i was using the mean so that
outline it would really influence what
was replaced so one of the exercises is
to write a function that computes the
mean of the column ignoring values
larger and larger than a particular X
and plugs it back into the original data
frame so something that you could do
another option is let's say we have also
some outliers here but we know that once
they are above a certain threshold we
want to put for example the minimum and
maximum values that the instrument can
register so let's say for example that
where I have a minus 10 I should really
have a minus 1 and once I have a 10 I
should really have a 1 so like the
instrument is giving wrong values there
so to do that with this data frame again
ignore this is just to create it I can
use this very nice syntax and I say
select all the cells where the absolute
value is larger than 1 and poor
in the sign of that particular cell so
it gets here that where I had a 10 I get
it one and when I got a minus 10 I get a
minus one so you're basically cutting
your data frame questions up to here no
okay another nice thing that panda has
is that we can do a binary the
composition of categorical variable
because sometimes need to use some
algorithms that needs oh it's called
well they don't work with categorical
variable they work with variables that
have mean 0 and the variance 1 so you
want to fix that so let's take this
sector data frame I'll show it looks
like basically the sector data frame as
some size of companies per sector and
some revenue there and what I want to do
is to take this industries which are for
automotive energy infrastructure and
transportation and basically decompose
that into 01 data frame so the six
company is an energy company so I put a
one at energy and 0 otherwise the 15
company is an infrastructure company so
i put 1 here and 0 otherwise and so on
once I've done that it's very easy to
get to a data frame that has all the
automotive column the mean of the
automotive column 20 and the standard
deviation 21 by using the scale function
in the SQ learn pre-processing so you
can see 10 minute right you can see here
that I'm scaling by binary industries
and if i call the described method on
the scale binary industries I gather the
automotive
column as indeed a mean of zero
practically zero and a standard
deviation of practically one and the
same with all four columns at this point
I can do a regression that assumes that
this column have this properties here so
what I can do I can join back the skill
binary industries into client and I will
get the four new columns here again it
is very easy and fast to do with bundles
and a psychic learn so plotting in
feminist it is slightly less painful
than metal wave who likes fat wallet
yeah nobody oh just ignore you and you
but nobody tried clinking likes metal Oh
clip now I'm just kidding anyway panels
as this plot method on data frames and
also series which allows you to prop
things very easily so for example here I
want to plot we already showed up micro
sure yeah I want to plug the size as the
X the revenue as the Y in a scatter plot
and panda takes care of that for me you
may want to do you could also plot a
series so this becomes the index and
this is the value if you pass a series
which has a daytime index fund us that's
the right thing for you and it makes it
very nice so these are very nice index
and if you have multiple columns panels
will plot each column in a different
color and we'll put a nice legend here
for you with very little effort on my
part so here you can see that to plot
this guy here I just call plot the rest
is all the default of the library yes
man
is the legend getting placed in a
sensible place automatically or did it
just happen to go in the uploaders don't
worry what question because matplotlib
handles that by default usually so it
uses there's like I think it's best is
the setting for legend placement yeah
show and just wonder if that's going on
here on the background panda is using
metal lip so my guess is that is keeping
the default of metal lib is has but you
can also pass the legend keyword
arguments there and basically pandas
pass it on to the method of lip backhand
and it will do the right thing so under
the hood plugging in partners is just
plotting in methyl methyl clip with a
lot of defaults to handle this sort of
data bar plots are also possible again I
just have to pass plot and then with the
right kind I can do horizonte burp
barplot passing an H at the end actually
stack plot if I want the look very nice
again very little things I had to write
after I get my data in place so this is
getting my data in place and plotting
it's just I don't know 20 characters 3
max if you use metro flip you know that
it usually takes a bit more writing to
get it right histograms are also
possible so you just pass the hist
keyword a method sorry with a binge
keyword and partners does the bidding
for you and that's the plumbing for you
if you don't pass the beans QR it tries
to optimize the number of pins depending
on the data you have but it's not always
what we want so you can override it like
this pandas also offers KD KD heat
distribution which is kernel density
estimate distribution similar to the
seaborne library again it's very you can
very little lines of code the first line
we will plot the KDE and in the second
line we plot the histogram note i know
that this data is different than this
data because i'm calling random twice so
I'm not so I mean it's not an error it's
by it's by design again there are many
more things you can do with pandas and
they're plotting things in pandas and a
lot of damage were very similar to what
seaborne offers deciding what you want
to use it's a trap about you I mean I
usually just use partners for
convenience II and if I need to do more
complicated stuff I try to use Seaborn
see what is also working really hard to
integrate nicely with pandas so it has a
cost of columns and sort of stuff so
there are it's very good data
aggregation of grouping who knows so the
group I in seq oh okay almost everybody
I see so basically in the blue by we
want to select a particular category
from our data and then apply a function
that category the glue by machinery in
pandas is where punish really really
really shines so things that the pundits
can do here are much more terse concise
the faster than what seek you can do and
we'll show a bit so this is the client
data frame we can see that we can glue
by sector and then take the median of
the revenue and this is what we get I'm
going to quickly skip this slide we can
also take the mean for example or two
columns and again partners very quickly
giver gives us the answer now if we want
we can very quickly convert the wide
data into long data by using stack so
here basically i'm writing this and then
stack at the end and you get this out
you have other methods built-in like
count min max median and so on and
something that you don't have in CQ is
that you could actually just get a
grouped object here and then do
something with it and you can see that
every group object contains the name of
the group and then the data frame which
is a sub selection or what you had in
that group you could also group in a
different way so let's say this is the
data we have and we want to do a
grouping with older even and odd members
of the indexer we have question there
I'm just wondering if you also have
something like a having clothes like an
SQL rd you know having if you combine it
it's yeah where you are doing area I'm
Blair group I yeah I kind of think about
it now my brain can't be fried but I can
think it in the break so you come back
and I think you can do something similar
but it's just I need to focus a bit to
reply to that thanks i have always
excuse for a difficult question so here
I'm having this dictionary that says
that the zero is even one is out and so
on and I can pass this dictionary to the
group I and then take the mean and what
panels will do will intelligently say
this is the mean for all day a even and
it is the mean for all the a odd it's
very powerful alternatively if you don't
have the dictionary you can pass a
function a function to that grew by and
saying I want to grew by again by even
and odd and you get the same result also
very powerful so you you pass a function
this function gets applied to the index
and the result of the function
determines the grouping easier if you
have a multi index you can also grew by
different level of the index so again
ignore this code here and concentrate
here we have a multi index on the
columns by province and by these numbers
here and I could say I want to get the
mean of / province along the along the
row so you get here six which is the
mean of 675 and you get here six again
with which is the mean of 91 and one so
again the syntax is you pass the level
and then you pass the axis you can
define your own aggregate function so
here for example you want the distance
between the maximum and the minimum and
you can pass this function to the AG
keyword and you will gather well the
difference between the maximum and the
minimum on revenue and size again if
this is supposed to be a numpy array so
these are vectorized operation very
quick other methods work very good in
for a grouped object so again we saw
that a group object is just an object
containing the various group and you can
just call described on them and it will
give you four data frames and they will
be stitched together so this is like
calling the scribe on each of the
sectors and let me see the time i can
probably close by showing
the transform keyword and what it does
so what a transfer keywords does it does
like the aggregate function but when
what it does is that it sticks back the
average into the original data frame so
you can see that this is the regional
data frame but tennis added a column
with the average of the sector so this
is the average of the sector so every
time you get an energy company you get
the same number here this is something
that you can achieve with window
function in c qo and it is very powerful
and from the last slide because of time
or you could you could do mean stuff as
well so it's very powerful the last life
as this that what comes back to the
question from an ACO and i want to get
the largest company by size and sector
so in order to do that i use the group i
apply the group i apply basically takes
each group's data frame it applies the
top and function the top end function
takes a data frame it sorts by a
particular column in this case the size
and then in descending order and it
takes the top two so you can see already
the group by the apply the result is the
original data frame but with the
automotive sector just the two largest
companies by size and the energy sector
with a two largest company by size and
so on a bun let's stick that back
together automatically for you and I
have I think probably 20 25 slides more
you can do it I mean with exercising so
I guess like to do it at home or
whatever question there from an echo
again
hello so I was ordering maybe you could
clarify some of the similarities and
differences in performance and
flexibility when you compare pandas to
our packages such as a deep liar and
data table very bad bias answer here as
I said before Wes really from the very
beginning of panels it put a very a lot
of effort into making it fast and it
really shows at sometimes he basically
research state-of-the-art algorithm for
example to do the value counts i think
which is much i mean at least used to be
much faster in partners than in our and
i don't want to say that our community
is catching up on this but it's not
always as fast i would say purely
because from the beginning the focus was
we need to make it fast and we have
performance tests so if you're adding a
new feature into bundles you need to
have a certain level of performance so
everything is c plus plus or see under
the hood so everything can get to the
same speed but i really i mean i like
puns more short
so thank you due money no more questions